my guest tonight stars as negan in the
walking dead
and the new film the unholy which is in
theaters
right now please welcome jeffrey dean
morgan sir how are you i'm very good
thank you for having me cody
i'm thrilled to have you i know you're
in georgia right now
and you're shooting uh the new and final
season of walking dead
people are losing their minds about that
but
i am told that you spent a lot of the
pandemic on a farm tell us more about
that
well yeah we uh my family has a farm in
the hudson valley so i've got 120 acres
and it's a
it's a working farm it's got a lot of
rescue animals and so i was there with
my wife and two kids and
you know 50 animals or so and so uh
we were good we were pretty
self-contained uh
throughout the majority of the pandemic
until i had to go to work again
um just having fun at missed mr farm you
know i'm curious about something this
sounds like
you know you come across to me anyway as
a manly man a man's man
you know how to do a lot of i appreciate
that and i mean that in the way that you
thought i meant it
uh you i picture you being able to like
split wood and take care of stuff
on the farm can you do that stuff i
can't and i do
i i in fact the splitting wood is one of
my favorite things
to do i'm a little bit obsessed with
that yeah yeah so i mean i can i can run
the farm
yeah now for sure i want you to be
honest with me jeffrey because we've
known each other a while
how do you think i'd do on the farm
let's say i pulled up on the farm
and uh you know just showed up
and said put me to work how do you think
i'd do
you know i i don't think i would put you
in that position
look i think you're very handsome and
very funny
and her eyes are very beautiful but i
just
i can't see you
so you don't think i could work you
don't think i could uh work a chainsaw
you don't think i could do that i would
that would be maybe the last thing that
i would give you was a chainsaw i
i can't imagine you with the chainsaw
maybe a little teeny electric one but
yeah like a gas power thing i think that
would be dangerous for everyone
you know but again handsome beautiful
man
who i think after a hard day working on
the farm i'd love to have
beer with you sure yeah that i could do
[ __ ]
that i could do i could you know what i
could do i could be
inside the farmhouse uh recording things
on your dvr
and uh you could do that yeah and then
getting the drinks ready for when you're
done with all the manly stuff
maybe making me like a chicken pot pie
you know i could make you a chicken
yes all right that's no freaking doubt
i i got an apron for you oh man i see
you know this is a good day
now we're doing well um i had a very
nice time yesterday hanging with
an old uh cohort of yours stephen young
he was on the program and we were
chatting and stephen and i have been
tight over the years and i've always
thought
i found out that you were coming on the
show today and i got i found myself
tightening up a little bit and feeling
and feeling
hostile towards you and then i was like
what is that all about and then i
remembered oh yeah
jeffrey murdered my friend i did
you murdered my friend but you know what
in
thinking about this and i need to talk
to steven about it i feel like i should
get like an assist
on the academy award nomination because
had i not tapped him with that baseball
bat
he'd still be on the show and now look
at him now he's all
in the spotlight big star and
doing brilliant work so you know it's
funny because it did occur to me that
you probably did him a favor you uh you
know he did like seven eight seasons on
that show
you came along and you said it's time
for you time for you to do some uh
oscar-nominated performances in movies
i'm tapping you out go out there and get
up yeah you you practiced
you you you you've honed your craft here
on the walking dead now
go be free you know i don't i'm i'm uh
you know in a similar vein uh you um i
never even realized this
but you had a scene which is one of the
most memorable scenes
in the history of the walking dead
where you also kill a very beloved
character and i didn't realize this was
a
improvised line there was an improvised
line in this scene
you know this you know the line i'm
talking about i know what you're talking
about i mean it's kind of the same scene
that uh
yeah that we lost the glenn in um
you are talking about a line improvised
by
the one and only michael cutlets yes i
believe
yeah that's an infamous line and
you guys should be in the writers guild
because he improvised
this line and then you improvised your
reaction to it can you take us through
that
yeah can you take us through that in
that moment well
it's kind of uh you know in the middle
of negan's introduction
in his huge monologue where he kind of
uh
kills glenn or kills abraham first um
and so in the middle of this monologue
uh abraham michael cutlet says
suck my to negan
uh or maybe to jeff what you know either
way and then i
you know we had rehearsed it and never
heard the sucker so when the cameras
were rolling he threw that out
and i started laughing um all of which
made the scene i started giggling and i
looked at everyone else in the lineup
and i'm like did you hear what he just
said he just said suck
mine um and so they kept that all
and sucked my has kind of become
michael's
thing um and now we go to like we'll do
an occasional convention
or i just get stuff sent here to sign
comic books or baseball bats or whatever
it might be
and sometimes they have the whole cast
so it'll go to someone's house first if
it goes to cutlets house first before me
he writes always suck my michael cutler
um so that becomes his little thing can
you imagine
what it's like to be him because
wherever he goes in the world because
we're talking about a world famous uh
show you can't go anywhere on the globe
and people don't know walking dead
anywhere uh michael cutlets goes uh
people point to him in any language and
say suck my
yes i'm sure he is he nailed it with
that one um
your character uh negan spent a whole
season in jail
and and i remember this because in a
strange way it was almost a precursor to
what the rest of us
went through in quarantine for a year
your character for a whole year was in
jail and it really
felt like you were losing your mind
because you were
because negan is such you know raw
energy and you were confined and you
could see
almost you as an actor using that to
have fun
yeah well he needs the people he needs
an audience
and that's where he kind of got his mojo
he was always sort of
putting on a show for the folks um
and so a year in jail was
and literally i never i was in jail the
entire season you never
saw me out i i had scenes with very few
people um
and and i just kind of went and went
nuts um
everybody may know this story i've
talked about it before but it's when i
decided well let's see if i can
cut my hair with you know basically a
butter knife
um and i i cut my scalp up but you know
i
and these were ideas that i thought by
the way that were really good yeah
in my head i'm like this is great i am
now
fully messy but also it's so funny
because you didn't do it as your
character
i mean you did but you did it jeffrey
dean morgan did it
and you did it with a butter knife and
you didn't consult anybody
you cut your own i just showed up at
work with this and um
you know everybody's just like they
think i'm a crazy person anyway but that
really sort of sealed the deal
you know what happened to your hair well
i i decided last night would be a good
time to
cut it with a butter knife um and it was
you know i i really did like
i had bleeding going on and and on stuff
uh and i've never done anything like
that before which sort of is a testament
to
isolation made me crazy yes even even uh
acting isolation where i still had a
crew around i still
got into my head and went nuts i've
actually told people because
i've spent a year without an audience
over a year
and i'm in a room right now in an empty
theater with some cardboard cutouts
and people have asked me what is that
like for you
someone who's so needy for laughs and so
needs an audience and it's occurred to
me
it's reminded me of like remember when
negan was in jail for a year
that's what it's like that's what it's
like for a comedian
that's perfect it's a really good
analogy and i so
get it now everyone of course
um excited slashed uh freaking out a
little bit that this is the last season
of the walking dead which is i mean this
show has been such a part of the culture
for so long
there's talk that there's going to be a
spin-off
is that right yeah i mean you might be
involved
we'll see it's definitely being talked
about um i think they're
they're they're thinking of a couple
different ideas but i've definitely
uh had conversations about possibly
continuing the story of negan
um you know we just did the here's the
again story which was sort of the the
prequel
how negan became this guy um
and i shot that with my wife which was
so cool yeah how was that
it was awesome it was really i i i we
had so much fun and i think the episode
turned out really well
but we shot these six episodes we called
the
the covet episodes
we don't need that phone working um we
shot these coaches maybe that was
maybe that was uh you know what what if
what if they were calling you about
being in the spin-off and you just hung
up on them
yeah well oh well
you idiot we have time we've got still
another yeah okay okay i'll let it go 14
months
we're here for 14 months shooting this
year of the show
wow and then i'm told is this right that
uh you're uh uh your son is going to be
uh one of the walkers is that right he's
going to be a zombie in
they don't say zombie i'm using the
incorrect terminology but
he's going to be he's going to be a
walker in
this final season is that right maybe
that is correct uh he actually works
tomorrow
um uh we're very excited
he uh you know one of the other things
he's playing a a child walker which uh
if you've watched the show i think we've
had like one or two of them in 10 years
it just doesn't happen so
there's something very special about
that and and now that his wife
his wife his mom has been a walker and
now he gets to be a walker that's so
cool
i like that you're keeping it in the
family you know it's turned into a
little bit of a family business but it
you know one of the things uh
about the covet of it all is that
this year we're only using like say 20
zombies we've hired them
full time for the full year and so
they're a different zombie every
episode maybe more than one zombie and
so
gus is uh is also tested he's tested
along with the rest of the family
and so we know that uh he's good to go
uh
yeah and so it just has worked out
really well so he's 11
and he gets to be on the walking dead in
the final season and it's
super super exciting very bumpy i love
the irony that you have to have your son
tested so that he can play someone who's
succumbed to a terrible virus
it's very matter it's crazy yeah yeah
yeah
and we also uh when we did those
episodes
we lived in the show's alexandria set we
actually lived in the rick grimes house
so the whole kind of experience of
of shooting and living during this time
and being associated with the walking
dead
has been very surreal in so many ways i
can imagine
i can imagine yeah uh let me ask you uh
about the unholy
uh this was this fun to make the unholy
this was me
you made this before the pandemic
obviously i made it
before and and during um but i think
i think it worked and the movie turned
out really well it's uh
you know sam raimi produced uh and it's
based on a james herbert novel
who was called the basically the stephen
king of
britain um and i think the movie is
is really cool and uh i'm thrilled i got
to be a part of it i'm really thrilled
we finished the damn thing
yeah we have a clip here from the unholy
is there anything we need to know before
i roll this clip
um i'm not exactly sure what the clip is
but i was told that it's scary
it's scary and it's dark and you're
looking under sheets
so uh okay well then there you go
[Laughter]
you know what for for zoom kovid
pandemic lockdown
that's not a bad setup all right let's
take a look yeah i like it
at this clip from the unholy
what
fun
foreign
i've seen that i love is that whenever
someone shows relief in a horror movie
you know the shit's about to hit them
that's exactly right and then it's
coming
yeah hey let me ask you quickly another
friend of mine is mr paul rudd
and i'm told there's a rumor that you
guys
co-own and co-run a candy shop together
is that right
we do co-own it where is this is this
in new york upstate new york it's in uh
rhinebeck new york so
uh we bought the candy store oh gosh
six seven years ago the owner uh the
previous owner
had it for 25 years kind of suddenly
tragically
passed away and he was a friend of ours
um
and we didn't want to turn anything else
and so we
we bought it and uh you know every now
and again you can go in and
get you know yourself a hot chocolate
with all behind the counter
that's what i've heard is that uh that
that rudd's actually there
maybe too much rud's hanging out at the
candy shop a little bit probably too
much
[Laughter]
yeah come on man you know the ant-man
thing is going really well you know you
don't need to put in so many hours at
the candy shop
but yeah exactly you know there's
there's a kid somewhere
that probably should be behind the
counter you know bringing home the bacon
he needs to go to school you're taking
his hours away yeah it's not right
it's not right let me get man yeah yeah
he's uh uh well he's a sick man uh the
walking dead
is available now on amc plus and uh of
course last season coming up and the
unholy is in theaters now
and uh jeffrey i gotta thank you too
because
i remember when we were at comic-con
about a year and a half ago or two years
ago
when negan and daryl show up and
uh that's about as happy as i've ever
seen a comic-con crowd
you guys were in a sketch and you played
it perfectly and it was hilarious
and uh you gave it was such a charge to
share a stage with you guys and see what
happens when you guys step out in front
of a comic-con mob
i also remember you drove motorcycles
over there through the crowd
that's right that's right pretty amazing
uh you were in that big theater
in downtown san diego theater
motorcycles
yeah yeah oh we had so much fun yeah
that was that was a fun that was a fun
night
that was it that was a dream come true
uh jeffrey indeed morgan you're a
gentleman
uh i'm happy for all your success
everyone check out the unholy
walking dead and onward and i'm gonna
come by the candy store i'll work a
shift
i promise oh please do uh yeah we'll get
you paul
and then i'll just eat the candy
[Laughter]
hey thank you jeffrey that was great
thank you very much thank you so much